okay hello everyone
we are talking about multi-computation
and
the well it's broken into several topics
the
the representation of the process of
evaluation
the
uh making of evaluation be not just
single path but multi-way
and uh
uh well
i guess we start off we also have talked
about um
okay
situationally aware function application
so where should we start should we start
talking about evaluation graphs um this
is this is the new stuff from ian that
correct here and we also have new stuff
from nick on evaluation graphs
that a true statement
in yeah
yes so that's a
mock-up of representing trace as a graph
using the two kinds of edges that we
discussed
okay so to understand this picture
okay this is evaluation of f of three
the fibonacci
and this dotted line horizontal dotted
line
represents a transformation rule is that
correct
yep and the solid line and the vertical
direction
represents a
recursion into the expression
yep
and
what does this this dotted line here
represents
basically just the fact that that thing
survived from there to there to be used
in here is that correct
yeah you're matching the result of
evaluation
into the next step
and is there a well-defined i mean why
would we not just go from that token
effectively
directly into
i'm confused by this well so
this way every
expression ends up getting represented
as a tree
so the point is this is kind of a graph
where the nodes are entire trees
okay
so people who know about the whole
multi-way world
uh which
it's not as many people okay
this
this is like a global multi-way system
is that a true statement or this is a
single wave version of a go what if we
went
i'm confused here
so essentially there's an edge from f of
3 minus 1 plus f of 3 minus 2
to
f of two
okay so here
this wants to get to here
and the way i'm representing that is
just by connecting
all of the leaves
i'm i'm confused here so this f of three
minus one
ultimately is going to turn into f of
two yes
but
the
things turning into things edges
are
two kinds the horizontal are ones where
a transformation was made
the
pseudo vertical
are ones where so they will always
connect identical nodes
okay
um
like so you have an f from an f and a
two to a two
okay
okay
nick is this relevant directly to what
we're talking about right here or is
this something different
it should be relevant it's a another
representation of how
multi evaluation can work
not not the trace as it it is right now
but
all the possible paths how you can
evaluate it
oh i see so this is this is the multi
case because this case here is still the
single way case
this case here is drilling inside the
evaluation for a single way computation
and right and i think the left is the
actual trace of the
standard evaluation sequence and the one
on the right is
the more fundamental operation of
just applying rules
okay so
the claim is this is a representation of
the evaluator
and the representation is
if you see f of 2
this here could be a labeled edge that
corresponds to an event
that is the
apply the definition of f event i mean
in other words this edge could be
labeled with a transformation right f of
f of n blank colon equals whatever yeah
correct
and it might be useful to do that
because
in a bigger version of this picture
that
transformation rule be sort of floating
out there in the ether pulled in to that
edge
to produce this result
right making sense
yep
um
but that edge is labeled that way
now
this
edge can somebody unravel this nick
james somebody else is this like a
causal edge in our world
what the heck is that edge that goes
from f to f
do we have any analog of that
no idea i mean we would usually just
have
what nick like a loop in the graphs that
we've seen before
oh yeah if it's like the same f
with the same semantics
then yeah
but here it's like
something happened to it it may be
getting being observed or something
well okay what happened to it is that it
is being put in a new expression
in my mind it's a position spec encoding
no but this this it being inserted in a
new expression this is like in the
combinator case
these weird
uh
re
repositioning links
in um
let's take a look here
uh
there is this idea
of a um
kind of in the dag
let's see where i have this
a lot of irrelevant stuff here
let's see
oh there we go this might be it
okay this is a rewrite
in which
the f has been shared there
and when the f has been shared
after
i don't know if i discuss that here i
discuss that somewhere
after the sh that's right the shared f
has to be
something might happen to it but it has
to be reinserted back into the
expressions it came from
if that makes any sense so nick
can we treat the f
as
a token
um so we have these can we treat these
as two different states
and the f is a token that belongs to
both of them nick
with this with this framework yeah
it's very close yeah it's it's also
related to the globalisation of choices
right so this is where nick's you know
um choice to include states into tags
can come in handy
right okay so but basically what you're
basically gonna say is that this f of
three minus one
is going to be a state and the f is
going to be a token that's right
yeah
and then what this is saying is that
certain tokens
boy what's weird is this tree-like
separation where a token can have
sub-tokens
and and the thing is that the
transformations can happen
at any level
in this
expression tree like the three minus one
could be transformed
oh here it is let's say if you had a
function oh sorry
gone well here it is like an implicit
state
is also created here you can say that
your initial expression is
being mutated
at that particular position
so every time you look at the sub
expression and decomposition tokens it's
like you're making up a new
original expression so it's like a new
state altogether so it's not like you
just
drilling down into one token and
decomposing it it's still you you it's
it's like you're
decomposing the initial expression again
okay so you're suggesting that there
really aren't
sub tokens so to speak any sub token
that you can imagine is just another
different position
such a different sub expression
different subtree that belongs to that
state
is that the idea
well the thing is you can't modify
if you modify the three here or if you
modify the three minus one
you are implicitly modifying f of three
minus one
well so can can i make a point about um
functions with like a hold attribute
they wouldn't have
those tree edges downward
because
you only have the tree edges
precisely when you're doing the standard
evaluation sequence
so if you had a function with a hold
attribute then you would just have a
node with a horizontal line to another
node
i understand
right and so
they genuinely are new expressions
because what you're doing is you're
evaluating the sub expressions so
the fact that there's an f to an f
that's just because f evaluates to f
i understand that you know if you kind
of had an own value that'd be like f
goes to
something else look the weird part about
this is this whole thing this f of three
minus one
to f of 2. it does that by sub parts of
it evaluating but then you have to
reconstruct from the sub parts you have
to what you've got is essentially some
kind of weird parallel transporty thing
where
there's this
representation of the expression which
is f of three minus one
which is subdivided like this
right because this is a very different
okay
because it doesn't hold its arguments
yeah assuming it doesn't hold its
arguments
there's a notion of subdivision edges
and there's a notion of equivalence
edges
see this f of three minus one being
joined to three minus one
that isn't the same kind of thing as
three minus one being joined to two
because that edge is fundamentally an
equivalent statement of some kind
or
yeah this is equivalent under
transformation to this
whereas this
is known to be drilled out
yeah this is saying i need to evaluate
three minus one in order to evaluate f
of three minus one
which somehow relates to causal graphs
in the i mean in other words in order to
in order to do the evaluation of f of
three minus one but that is sort of the
definition of a causal graph is it's
giving you the causal dependence you
know the event you are about to do what
events have to have already happened to
be able to do that event
and here
what we're saying is
to evaluate f of three minus one we have
to already know what happened to three
minus one et cetera et cetera i mean it
almost feels like
this should be a dependency the other
way up
like this seems like it's going down and
saying f of three minus one turns it
into three minus one but it doesn't it's
three minus one contributes to f of
three minus one
did that make sense you start with f of
three minus one
and then you transform it
by transforming its
uh parts
yes but what i'm saying is that the
those parts
i think there's like the are you doing
the replacement in place or
you know are you constructing a new
expression
kind of thing
no i i'm really not saying that
let's take a look okay i think i
understand do people understand this
picture basically
and how much by hand was this done is
this is this like literally done by hand
or is that the embedding is by hand
there is code in
there
in the
cell okay are these these ones that are
automatic or so the top one is what you
would automatically get
just the g equals trace graph of f three
gives that
my gosh
and who can understand this
you really need the embedding
um
the the the point of the embedding is
that horizontal the horizontal axis
always represents transformation rules
and the vertical axis always represents
um
like sub-expression recursion accepted
that's violated vertical action it's
violated in the automatic embedding so
no i understand but the the vertical
axis the vertical direction also
is this stay the same
you know thing
well it's only there because you did
sub-expression recursion you had to
evaluate plus
yeah but the evaluation is not
horizontal you're telling me evaluation
is horizontal but it isn't
because this evaluation which did
nothing is vertical
i'm saying anytime you have an
evaluation you're going to at the very
end of it have a vertical edge
connecting the result of that evaluation
to
the sub-expression in the new expression
so you're right that plus doesn't have a
horizontal because no transformation
rules were applied
so you're saying i'm saying the top is
the input
and it evaluates to
plus okay but i'm i'm pulling this back
to saying
you know we're generating we're going to
fix points
and what you're now saying is once you
reach a fixed point there really three
things that can happen
okay a transformation
a drill down
and a fixed point
that is just transported to the future
right so the first two you either do a
transformation or a drill down those are
the two operations
you do those continuously until you
reach a fixed point
either one any mixture of them any
mixture of functions with different
attributes yeah okay
so they're together
and then
no matter how you got the result of the
evaluation at the very end when you
reach the fixed point you have a
vertical edge connecting that fixed
point into its corresponding part in the
next step
and why does that two not have an
outgoing edge
it well because you did trace original
goes to this is trace original goes to
um
oh no it's because the two is already
evaluated two was the result of three
minus one
okay but why doesn't it have doesn't it
survive it doesn't need to it does not
need to re-evaluate
because it's the result of something
that's already evaluated and no
transformation rules have been applied
i see so this is in fact the
reevaluation attempt
a vertical line is a failed reevaluation
attempt well a vertical line is an
evaluation
so you mean a strictly vertical
yes it's only strictly vertical if it
happens to be the furthest one to the
left
i see i'm just saying you always anytime
you've evaluated an expression are going
to end up somewhere with a vertical edge
from the result to the next step
i think i understand all right let's
take a look at next
thing over here is this is this would be
possible to just emit the last like
that that last reevaluation edge or does
it not
work if you do that
you're talking about the three to three
at the very end
yeah like i mean if if you're always
gonna get if it's always gonna be the
case that you know the last step when
when reevaluating it doesn't change
anything
no maybe you could emit that edge
promise how does this plus get itself
reinserted down here
that's what i like
for example look at the three minus one
horizontally goes to two
and then from there vertically goes to a
two
all right three minus one
the the lower three minus one
so that how did it go wait wait how did
the three minus one go from there to
there well so three minus one
doesn't have any special transformation
rules
you
apply
you evaluate its arguments so plus
evaluates a plus three evaluates the
three minus one evaluates to minus one
you get three minus one again
you apply a transformation rule you get
two
okay but but this three minus one here
not actually there's no edge from the
top three minus one to the bottom three
minus one well what what is that little
thing about the three that's the edge
from the three to the three
going down though that's confusing it
looks like there's an edge yeah it's
overlapping
okay but so is it the case that for
every kind of uh
inert object you know like a two or like
a plus
you know that there'll be a vertical
edge from it to itself
with trace original goes to true yes
okay but would it be i mean brace
original
is explicitly the thing that hides that
if you have an expression that just
evaluates to itself it doesn't show up
oh i see does that make it like
disconnected or something weird like
that or does it just work it's just a
bit less hairy
well so we were looking at the trace
original goes to false above
and
basically you just end up with less with
fewer duplicates okay but i'm still very
confused about this three minus one
giving a you know three minus one
it breaks apart into its constituent
parts which evaluate
yeah
then you
look at the thing that you've gotten
which is three minus one
it's just the tree
but how did it get from that three minus
one to this three minus one here that's
what i'm saying there is no edge from
the three minus one to the three minus
one that that's why i'm talking about
parallel transport but it's somehow the
plus goes to the plus the three goes to
the three the minus one goes to the
minus one
and if you make a tree out of those
three things
that's three minus you had before as it
turns out in this case but only then i'm
just labeling that node with this is
super confusing it's only then after the
evaluation i construct like you
construct i i understand but after
reconstruction then it goes in to
evaluate the the main head mm-hmm
i think this is confusing i think this
is plus doesn't hold its arguments yeah
right
but i think there's got to be a better
way to do this
to that doesn't have the weird
redundancy of this thing back up that's
just trace original goes to false okay
but this thing just to complain again
this thing
goes down to evaluate its arguments
flows back up to here then flows back
down to here no i'm i'm saying it goes
down to the plus down to the three down
to the minus one
those things flow down to the plus the
three and the minus one
oh i see and then those flow back up
again here to the three minus one
yeah using construct basically
okay well i'm gonna be interested to see
next token event graph version of this
okay this is that's the version where
you don't see the redundancy
you see the three minus one you don't
see another three minus one with
everything just being trivially
connected to a copy of itself
is there any value to having the trivial
connection to the copy of itself
um
not obviously okay
yeah i mean it's easier to implement and
we have that option already so i don't
know
okay all right fine
so let's see so nick should we talk
about this now or should we go to your
talking about graph
thing
we can briefly talk about this one
okay all right so
this is simply like
manually construct the rules it's like
you insert your down values and see what
happens
you just have to hack around something
about how you evaluate plus
okay but but the basic point here is
that um by the way i'm just looking at
where these things are getting saved
um did that get saved in the appropriate
place
i have this notebook in the our
multi-computational folder already okay
multi-computation supply trace was
already there you can you can replace it
i i put it in there before the meeting
started okay fine mean i don't want to
replace it i'm not supposed to do that
one okay okay
um
uh okay so let's go here just for a
second
um
okay so if i were to take this code here
so i understand this is a multi-replace
on expert using the fibonacci rules
so let me try to understand this so
there's an event that turns it into that
that is using the fibonacci rule as an
event
this is another
event
now i understand why it's turning into
why that event has two outcomes there
because it's uh
still one event because here it is event
is a simple application of multiple
place and multiple points produces
multiple results
on what happened
so the event here either expands f of 3
or it expands f of two is that correct
yeah
transforms one or the other of those
or is it that it does both
no it does it does one going this way
and one going that way
and so
this is a confluent system
which regardless of what order these
things are done in always leads you to
three
that's right i just want to see the
thing just for fun i want to see a um
okay so
just for my understanding
um
this is interesting i mean this is this
is basically okay so this is multi-way
fibonacci recursion
and any particular so left most
outermost so we should be able to label
this
with you know left most outermost goes
down one side is that right
actually we didn't even get to the end
here let me just go to the end
oh my gosh we didn't get now that that
should have gotten to the i mean
by this point
okay so there are two kinds of events
here one is
an addition event and the other is well
maybe three kinds an addition an f
transformation no just it's just one
kind
it's just multiplies contains
all kind of rules maybe it's like we i
could make
different events by just
like applying different rules
i see okay
so your multi replace here
has
it's greater than two in active plus
otherwise this blah blah blah
what the heck is that rule there
basically
oh i see that's saying that the
that's saying that inactive plus is
going to turn into active plus
that's interesting
but only if we introduce right
it's not a complete
it's not an exact way how evaluation of
this thing works but
somehow you can expand more like how you
activate
plus on something else and so on
okay so that for example it doesn't do
the simplification here
of saying that
there are two f of twos here
which can be combined
yeah
so
just so i understand the the path that
corresponds to the usual recursion the
usual evaluator is a particular path
here can we easily find that path
and we should try a simple case where is
the evaluator path
f of three plus f of two
and then the next step for the evaluator
is actually none of these paths it's a
combination isn't it
well it always evaluates one
sub-expression at a time i know whereas
the evaluator
actually effectively evaluates multiple
sub-expressions
doesn't it i mean
what what would this look like what
would the path that corresponds to the
leftmost
path
i think is the sequence that you would
get from the
evaluator
so there you evaluate you would end up
evaluating f of two first
i think you're right
okay let's see if it's still the
leftmost path here
you might be right
okay
now in this case
uh all evaluation parts are the same
like for example
right and okay so that's
but now
although they aren't necessarily the
same work because they could be
different sizes of expression on the way
down and so on
okay i think i understand this
so that's a single multi-replace
and the single multi-replace here has
like two outputs one it evaluated the
three by using the inactive plus goes to
plus rule and the other evaluated f of
three by doing this
yep
okay
okay so this is essentially how
so is it the case that you could make a
picture like this for any
uh for any evaluation of making the
evaluation multi-way
i think so if you do some preprocessing
on the rules or the down values
somehow
but so basically every
expression
[Music]
would naturally turn into an active
version of it
but then you'll have to have rules like
this
that progressively recurs and evaluate
yeah right i mean so you would basically
have to write the evaluator as a replace
as a list of replacement rules
well right and neck doesn't yet have the
problem here
of any kind of drill down in the
evaluator this evaluator is only its
only evaluation step is to replace you
know
inactive plus with plus
at the top level so to speak
it didn't have to do drill down and then
replacement
that's not the top level
what do you get if you
if you get rid of the blank integer
on the x
let's try it
like will the right answer still be in
there somewhere but it just takes
more paths
triple
i'm not sure i want triple
i think triple might blow up
my gosh what the heck is this doing
i think now you have like an effect of
activating plus it also commutes your
arguments
okay so that's causing some equivalences
that weren't there before is that what
you're saying
yeah and then you this pause because the
rule expects
an active pass on the left-hand side
it's it's not
getting replaced anymore
what's not getting replaced anymore
oh so plus after you've done one plus
it no longer knows to replace that plus
because it is now a naked a raw
evaluatable plus not an inactive plus
yeah yeah
okay
all right were you going to show some
talking about
technology or is this it
next no the the technology the only
technology that you can add an
additional option to this token graph
you can even try it for this one
it's like it's called state vertices
goes to true and there's like an
additional type of vertex is going to be
added
that indicates states
and now it's like no longer a bipartite
graph but
it's like a two-party graph whatever
okay what the heck is going on here so
those
bluish vertices greek blue green
vertices those are state vertices
right
and
and
the idea that you have some kind of
operation of how would you decompose
your states into tokens and how you
recombine tokens back into states
by default
the recombinations
is just an identity so your state is
just a list of tokens so in this point
in this case it's just
a list of expressions
or sets why is this a state i don't
understand why this is a state because
these all seem like completely different
expressions
yeah they're just being combined into a
state
which would be just a set of tokens
but if all this is the state
but you can by defining your own
recombination and decomposition
functions you can make different kind of
states
for example if your
token would be labeled by position
you would you can write a function that
can make a tree out of tokens or an
arbitrary expression
so your state would be an expression
again
i'm fairly confused
i mean
why do the events okay so we made this
state here
this state is a multi-way combination i
mean so in this direction it's the
branch shield direction this is not the
tree direction this is a bronchial
direction going from here to here these
are different branches in the multi-way
graph correct
getting to these different tokens
is that true statement
yeah yeah
okay so then all these branches are
combined into a state which has
branchial extent
that state has branchial extent it's not
a you know there's some states that you
might say have some kind of tree-like or
spatial extent
like there are lists and they have
multiple things that are almost like
different places in space or some kind
of expression that is um
uh
but nick the state should have some in
many cases
three the state should have some
tree-like extent but the tokens
basically being sub-trees
it depends how you make a state
it can be not even be unique
it's like every type you every time you
combine tokens into states
it can be more than one state it's like
in this case the default
behavior is just make one statement all
the tokens
at each step of your evaluation do you
have a simpler yeah yeah right
what's another example did you have a
file of examples nick
i have
one example where it's like have
multiple states
okay
where is that
well in the multi-computation folder
there is a token statement graph
okay what the heck is this
okay that's an ordinary
nm goes to n times n and minus m
okay
a token recombination function
all right what the heck is this
i have some zoom problems sorry okay
lost my window
um okay does anybody else understand
what's going on here well
on nick is recovering his
so there's a times and there's a minus
on that edge
i see that event
generates a times piece and a minus
piece
let's generate two different tokens
and they're labeled what
which one is generating which token
so this is essentially a graph with
ports
where you're specifying are you back
yeah i am back
this is just a feature that you can tag
every output
or even every input if you have an
association
but the point here is that you have
multiple states
by giving a some kind of recombination
function that makes multiple
states
okay
but you've already got a different thing
which is quite interesting which is the
ability to have a graph
whose
outputs are edges that are tagged like
this we don't have that an ordinary
graph right
if i say graph of
you know a goes to
let's say
um x goes to b
y goes to a i don't believe that does
anything useful
i don't know what that's doing
well this is going to be
this is going to make a vertex
which is an association
boring yeah okay but so that's the type
of syntax that we would need for a a
graph with ports isn't that right could
you also do a undirected edge in an
association
yeah
so how does that help i think i mean
then what if you have an association on
both and what if you want a vertex that
is an explicit association
yeah well that's an issue okay no i mean
all right fine so it probably needs a
wrapper
to be something that you know a ported
rapper or something or a ports rapper
am i making any sense i think there's
nobody from the gras theory
group here
but
but i'm just trying how is it different
by just adding a text
tag to the page what how we want it
it may not be different
uh
can i add the tag in order to add the
tag i have to explicitly say graph of
abc for example and then i've got the
edges
tagged what is it called
oh no edge it's just a
it's just a directed edge and you can
add a third argument
right
are ports i i don't i'm not familiar
with graphs with ports but are the ports
we don't have them yet
i mean just
the idea of them um
but would they be just labeling what's
that are they ordered things like this
port yes or this one
oh i don't
accomplish that
uh
you're
saying ordered i see you're saying
ordered as in tag one comes before tag
two
in the description of tags yeah and even
without an association just ordering for
the
i guess that's mostly useful in a dag
or a tree
where you might want ordered siblings
right i mean the limiting case of this
is a tree the limiting case of a graph
with ordered ports is presumably a tree
well tree is more restricted
than that no i understand that but a
tree is an example
of a
tree could be made by making a graph
with ordered ports
true statement
yep
okay
so nick what should we understand here
from this picture
now
i think the main point here is that you
also have
additional multicomputation
i don't know
how how do you code the fact that this
the state can be multiple states
multiple ways how you
produce states out of tokens
okay i'm still confused by this it's a
an additional multicomputation so where
where's the example where
you're producing different states from
the tokens because it seems like
here's an example
you have two states
at each
each time at each evaluation step
evolution step
your talk and produce tokens produce two
states
but yes
but they're distinct tokens just it's
not like the tokens are going
to different states it's just you have
the four and the zero are going to this
left state yeah and the one is going to
the state on the right
right
yeah what happens at this
can we evaluate it an additional step
does it get more
delightful you have an additional step
you you have like
separate events that act on different
states
i just wanted to see what
what happens next
i mean so
nick i mean when you were describing
before that you know your state you can
even you can treat your state as an
expression tokens can be you know
sub-expressions they can provide
basically position data about the state
that that was that was intuitive is
there some example we can take that's
more familiar
um where we take some
tag that we use say in metamath or
somewhere else that's quite familiar and
we just add these states um
maybe an example where the
where the states will be some clear
expression
some tree like
a nice
functionality when you have attacked
position tag tokens and then i recombine
them into expressions
what do these numbers
mean the two one et cetera what are
those those are just the indices of the
order
of the
tokens in this case i guess
so okay so this is saying
so in other words this statement that
four is at the two
index and zero is at the one to the next
means that in terms of wolfram language
representation that that
state there
is
zero four the list zero four am i right
right
can we can we show that can we put
labels on the on the states here
i think i do not store in the state
and this like
the state vertex at all
but the event kind of shows them if you
show the labels for events they show the
position
where those events been applied what
happened here we've got
lots of competitors for the two slot
what's going on
i'm not sure i'm not sure how i'm
labeling the in
state
i'm not sure how i've taken those edges
it's just some arbitrary attack maybe
okay all right okay fine
okay wait nick at the moment
is it not possible to
take a token event graph that we've used
before and activate this
new option
that you spent that you've included
what option
well this is
state vertices option that's what i was
asking before i mean token event graph
we've used token event graph plenty of
times can't we just take a more familiar
example of a tag
and oh if you
you should adjust this option turn it
most off we can i guess
no but what nick what what james is
asking is
in i mean things we've studied like the
n plus n and minus zen
but this is i mean this is fine there's
one like that
what is token recombination function
doing
just specifying how you
make those states out of tokens
here just makes two states one combines
odd numbers and another even numbers
okay
what is their default yeah default one
is just union basically
so it's always going to be one state
that
each step
oh yes
i see
okay so this is a essentially a
distributed tokens distributing tokens
to states
function
it's saying of the states that are there
how should these tokens be arranged
between the states
is that right
yeah
so if you're gonna think about
expressions
then it's gonna be more interesting how
you combine sub expressions into
expression again
because if the tokens tagged with the
position and they occupy the same
position then the
the states that it's going to recombine
are going to be multiple states
right because it's not it's not going to
be a unique way to make an expression
again
okay well let's try a different
way of
breaking up the states let's say for
example i want to break up
uh what does it return here is it a list
of um
yeah
a list of states
whatever the state is
okay so it takes in tokens and it
returns a list of states
yeah it takes the list of tokens right
okay so if i were to say this thing
arrow identity
then every token becomes a state
is that right that's not quite what i
was expecting
list identity
you should drop it
oh you should take a
union also everyone
the default is list
list of union
list of apply union
because the input is not just the list
of tokens so this is the list of list of
tokens because they also
uh separated by
depending on what event
it corresponded
that's a very different result here
oh i'm confused i mean in this case i
thought was going to happen is it was
going to pick up every event was going
to end up being a separate token but
that's not what happened here
what was the recombination function
again
for this example just an identity
so
the input to the recombination function
the list
so we have like an output just a list of
output tokens
depending on what of the events so it's
going to be like
a list of lists of one
list of zero and if you make an identity
each of those make would make a state so
how many he went for there
that's how many states you're going to
get so i think it's correct
yeah well okay so if i but if i were to
say
for example flatten
there
because the tokens are getting renamed
just specify a level for the
button okay
yeah
oh no maybe not like that
list of categories you still
don't need to make a list
let's go only one step and see what it
does
okay so those two
gosh this is complicated
let me change the aspect ratio
make it wider
okay what's happening here
just all the outputs are just getting
combined into one state
so the state of the
second step is just
list of those five pockets
okay
okay
okay let's zoom out for a minute and
then we're going to turn to slightly
different things
so the zoom out is
between
what nick has got and what ian has got
we are working towards having an
evaluation graph i think
i would like to understand the
relationship between this and events
because these these edges basically have
events on them i think
and nick if you were to prune this to a
single way graph
you could you should be able to
systematically do that you would have
something which
okay
if we did that with something which
involves drill down so the only
difference in in the case without drill
down
the single way graph is just
a a path graph correct
yep so yeah
okay so with drill down
it becomes more elaborate basically if
every function if every function has a
hold attribute all the way until you get
to the end
you get a path graph
yes
yes because there's no drill down
okay
so meanwhile
sorry
i think it would be useful in the
diagram on the left to have two colors
for things that are
not evaluated and things that are fully
evaluated and then for example the the
first f in this vertical lines will not
be evaluated the lower f would be
evaluated and we would see that these
horizontal lines with dots would always
start with evaluated expressions
and that would justify why we need two
colors
and why
we have to go through the change of
color before applying the horizontal
lines
wait a minute you're saying
that
things that have
so look at the trace original goes to
true example
instead
this
okay
so
jose did you want to explain or
i i understand like the top f of three
would be a color representing that it's
unevaluated
and so was the f and the three but the
downward arrows would connect to
you know the f and the three at the
bottom would be
the color that represents
evaluated
extra so and so would the f of three but
the point is as soon as you do a
horizontal transformation rule that
connects an evaluated thing to an
unevaluated thing
so you have to go through the process of
evaluating the parts again until you
have an expression that is fully
evaluated and then it can
say develop a horizontal line again
but so yeah that's a good thing to do to
color that but i mean that coloring is
essentially you've reached a fixed point
if i'm not mistaken
yes but in this case you thought you
reached a fixed point with f of 3 but
then f 3 suddenly jumps to something
else
well it's not a fixed point it's like i
have evaluated all the parts so now i
can look at
replacement rules applied to the whole
thing
the fixed point for f 3 is 3 all the way
at the bottom
yeah i know
confusingly
um
well because it has to go through all of
this stuff first
yes i understand that but what i'm
saying is this f of three
after one evaluation no no it has not
done an evaluation yet
exactly it has evaluated itself parts
right okay so these things here are the
end of the line they're fixed points
they can get a different color yes yes
so that's why we need to do it plus
there has has a has a different color as
well yep yep
okay but but so the whole point is you
don't bob back up in the recursion in
the this in the tree-like recursion in
the evaluator until you have built
yourself on solid foundations
with our current evaluator
we don't recurse back to the top of the
expression again until all the subparts
are stable
correct
i think the the the confusing thing here
is that once you have evaluated the f's
and the threes
the f of three appears above and i think
it would be perhaps a bit more natural
if it appeared better yeah i i agree i
agree that was kind of what i was saying
except rather confusedly
that because it has to go down and then
up again
so here yeah that's a good point jose if
if what happens is this one is a
downward facing one and this one is a
flipped around sorry is it is it
it deconstructs itself downwards and
this one constructs itself downwards as
well it's it's tree layout top versus
trio layout bottom
yes exactly is it possible to change
that in this picture or is that way
too too custom
okay and how close is this picture to
actually being implementable
um
i mean it's just it's just tricky i
think there's like
you might be able to apply
some
like decomposition of this into
rectangles techniques that jose is
familiar with
for this
okay but the basic point here will be i
can
i can generate this graph at least with
the edges and vertices
okay now just to understand this is a
single way evaluation
where the two kinds of edges are
transformation and drill down
and the colors and there's this third
one
which is the
the stay the same i'm already a fixed
point i just want to be
it's just the building materials edge
where where you're transforming the
three into a three that will be used as
a piece of building material so to speak
to build back up the f of three
yep
okay
do we understand does nick understand
for example how this relates to his
graphs
so
his state nodes
correspond to the finished goods the
finished
constructed trees if i'm not mistaken
or could correspond to that
and the state node is then connected
through an event
to a new state node
nick did that make any sense i mean do
you understand this relationship before
well not quite i don't think the state
is being
produced every time
every time during the tracing
at all
you just every time you drill
doing the drill down you're not making
up the state again
okay
no but i mean look
this is the fact that the states are the
roots of these trees
which is that one there and then that
one which turns out to be the same
with an option to suppress it
so states are
like what if you make a slice for this
tree there
and
at each step and to combine it
at this particular step what would be
the
expression at this point
that would be a state is it always a
single expression or can there be
multiple ones
well for a simple variation trace is
going to be a single expression
it is unique
okay
okay
um
let me see
so okay but then
okay can you give me a sense of how do
we go multi-way from this picture
well maybe you make it wider
yeah but what's actually happening
what's happening is
what's happening is you have the
evaluator which is a lot of complicated
transformation rules that applying one
step of it goes from f of 3 to
plus of f of three minus one
f of three minus two
yeah
no i mean all the all the little like
sub detail in this is
just detail about that transformation
rule
not about different ways that it could
be applied
right as opposed to next
stuff over here
before we even get to the states thing
this is different evaluation paths
which are confluent in this case what is
the condition for them to be confluent
or is it always the case that any reason
i think it's always the case that any
reasonable functional programming type
thing will always be confluent
yeah i think the condition is that your
rules don't overlap it's like you don't
have a separate
f of n
this is doing like a completely
different thing
i see
so in other words at every point
okay so the condition for confluence is
that at every point there is unique
transformation that can be made
no not a unique
every subpart
see because this whole thing
has two transformations that it can be
made from here you can either expand the
f of
you can either expand the f two or you
can expand the f of one here
yeah well but if there is an overlapping
position
they happen
a different position but if they hover
up they should be unique
there only should be an equation of
doing it
are there are values in which you can
get that in which you can get this
overlap and non-confluence
i bet there are
i bet it depends on what
yes yes there clearly are it's like does
an up value if an up value is is um
uh
okay so the claim would be
um
non-confluence
can occur
without values
and i will i will claim
um
that an example of that would be h of f
of x comma g of x
and the question is who gets to grab
the up who gets to make use of an up
value the f or the g
do you get what i'm saying
yeah
i think that will be a case where
there's non-confluence
so i have to choose precedence for f4g
what does it actually do what does the
evaluator actually do in that case
anybody know i think it presumably picks
the f there
first
anybody jose christopher anybody know
what the evaluator actually does
you can you can achieve it with down
values
it's like it always speaks
the first rule with like the most
general one case whatever
what is the rule right
but
like all of them
well but normally the down values i mean
the way that works is that when you when
you add down values they get put into
this list and the list is sort of sorted
but up values are in a different list
so it can't just
you know
like with down values it's literally
going down the list and picking the
first one that's there right but this
will be on f list and there'll be a g
list for the two different up values
here
so i mean even things like i mean do
down values have no way up values have
precedence over down values right yes
okay so it goes down the up value list
first but then the question is which i'd
assume it goes down the left one first i
would assume that also
because i think that's the general
principle of left most
left most innermost evaluation or is it
in the most left most no it's left most
which one is it ian do you know from
your tree work
is it
outermost left most
all right but for for down values it's
for me
is kind of subjective like you're going
to go down and then you're going to go
back up either way
it's like do you visit do you apply do
some do you do some operation while
you're descending the tree or do you do
it while you're ascending the tree
like it's a depth first it's a like in
two in tree traverse order it's a left
most
or it's a left uh
left to right
depth verse traversal
right up values are yet a different
thing though because what up values ours
is just that every time it reaches an
expression to evaluate it does a quick
little check where it goes sort of down
level checks if there's anything to do
and then it goes back up
right because up values only work one
level down
right
and then there's also sub values and how
do they play with all of this i don't
know the details of this
right values i'd imagine are more like
down values but yeah i would think so
also
i think that in the end what should
happen is that there should be events
that are
essentially down value events up value
events things like this or something
like that
and
okay
so
what this picture illustrates is
that the c
series of intermediate expressions you
can get is different depending on which
if you are traversing the tree
there are different tree traversals
that will lead you where where you
perform
the
you know transformation on different
tree elements first
and this graph represents all possible
orders in which those transformations
could be chosen to be made and so the
different sub-expressions yeah i think
that's okay so i'm trying to understand
in this graph here so this is a single
way graph
my gosh this is confusing
and then the next question would be and
i mean it would be useful nick to see in
this multi-way setup
what a natural coding of something like
an n queen's problem or something would
look like here
or some trivial game type thing because
because then
what we should see
in other words if we were doing logic
programming what's the most trivial
logic programming example
what we should see is that this graph
in a logic programming case
has many different outputs
probably does not have confluence
and what we're asking is
what's the largest value that can come
out in any of those outputs let's say
following
you know
where we don't know the path and we
don't know
and we're looking at a collection of
outputs in other words this is
attempting to
turn this into something which looks
like logic programming as an example
right because i mean this case here
it's like
evaluation which you can do the
evaluation in different orders but
you're always going to get the same
result
it's also the case that these
transformation rules can define
something like logic programming am i am
i right about that
nick christopher anybody else in some
way it's like
i had this example with propagated
networks and those rules can be
somehow describing each propagator
then you fill the values
for example you feel the resulting value
that you want to achieve and then just
run the network and now the intermediate
value is getting filled
unless there is a contradiction if there
is a contradiction then contradiction as
soon as it becomes rejection appears
anywhere in the graph it can propagate
it around the whole network
i don't what do you mean propagation
what do you mean by that
well maybe you can show an example yeah
you want sure
just
give me a second can i find a notebook
again
or you can send it to me
okay but our big picture idea question
whatever
now
first objective here the evaluation
graph being able to show what it looks
like
next objective is
in the evaluation graph
be able to easily see what are the
possible
oh boy i mean what are the possible
evaluation orders and
from the graph graph theoretically
figure out what things can be done in
parallel like let's imagine we were
running this on gpus or something and we
wanted to split the thing up into
different threads or not gpus let's just
say multi-threaded
what could what attribute of this graph
would show us there can be different
threads like for example here probably
that block is separately from that block
a true statement
if you don't have side effects
well we're dealing with not let's deal
with a non-side effect case okay
and then then what i want to ask is in
this evaluation graph you should graph
theoretically be able to say what things
can be evaluated in parallel
i think if you assume there aren't side
effects then you could just switch every
depth first
thing to be a parallel breadth first
just trivially
okay
like instead of evaluating f of three
minus one and then f of three minus two
just
when you do the standard evaluation
sequence just evaluate all the arguments
in parallel
okay that's back to the parallel
attribute of smp
um
what happened christopher you might
maybe we're going to think about whether
there's a way to just try doing that i
mean is that
does our evaluator would our evaluated
code actually allow one to do that
just say assume no side effects
just switch on a parallel block
and then everything here every function
just gets all its arguments updated in
parallel
i mean i i think it's
i i don't know enough about about the
sort of you know internal workings of
the evaluator but i mean certainly there
would be things like like everything you
do will touch the symbol table in some
way you know every time you do a block
or every time you do a module and stuff
like that so i think it's it's more
complicated than you know just launching
a bunch of threads or something but it
you know it might still be possible
right you're saying that for example
module the module number is definitely
not going to be multi-threadable it
would have to be a uuid for example
maybe i mean they're probably there's
probably ways with like a mutex and
things of doing the module number but i
was even just thinking about the fact
that
uh you're creating symbols
which is
you know changing the symbol table
right i mean even if you just have a
program that just says you know
right unique or something
that's you know for forgetting about
module number it's already not gonna
you know right but that's not every i
mean the question is
could we set it up so that we can detect
this sub part of a program
is fully parallelizable every every
function here has or even just some
functions can be multi-threaded so so
this is basically i mean
right i mean in general functions that
are totally pure you can just run them
concurrently however you want i mean
this is one of the principles behind i
mean this is why haskell can have a lazy
evaluator
um
but
i think trying to
i mean maybe we can i'm thinking about
if it's really realistic to be able to
statically figure out if a program is
pure
i i'm i'm going to be a lot of functions
where it's easy to tell that
i mean i don't know whether yeah but
then there's things like i mean
for example if it uses module it's
technically not pure because it affects
the you know module number kind of thing
right so so i mean but you you want that
to be considered purer
yeah
no but you could imagine weird things
you could imagine weird cases where
the fact that it affects the marginal
number does actually cause problems but
yeah well okay but but let's imagine you
know thousands of functions are going to
be pure
slam dunk pure
i
claim thousands of functions there's not
going to be an issue at all
sure like binarize or yeah reverse
right i mean there is potentially an
internal issue because there's caching
and things that i have no idea whether
our caches are thread safe does anybody
have any idea
i think we have a uniform caching
infrastructure that's used with weak
hashes and so on anybody know about that
here
i'd be shocked if they're thread safe
but in addition to caches there's also
stuff like
you know there's random pieces of
functionality that that use you know
hash tables and stuff like i'm thinking
of um
for example some of the stuff that deals
with like message handlers like message
dollar message list i think that makes
like a hash table and it updates it as
it goes and stuff like that that's
something where
yeah figuring out how message lists work
with concurrency is a little bit funky
that's funky that's already funky with
parallel evaluate
another one would be a code that
includes
well
how aborts work because normally
well actually i guess aborts there's
probably a reasonable way to do the
boards but but like normally speaking
it's it's you know if you have like a
throw in one of these concurrent threads
it has to abort the other threads oh
before it you know goes up for example
look these corner cases are ugly but
that doesn't mean we can't make
something work for most cases yeah of
course of course i am just saying that
you know
you've asked several times you know
whether this is just like kind of a you
know an easy little thing where it's
like you'll have to write a small amount
of kind of tricky code that will then
magically make things run concurrently
and i'm saying i i'd be surprised right
so but my claim would be certain
functions we could tag
statically lexically we could say this
piece of code if it runs only these
functions
is you know is going to be okay to run
uh you know multi-threaded
um
i mean yeah i mean i would i would sort
of guess i mean that's kind of the
inverse of so the thing we talked about
before was having an attribute
you know where the arguments of a
function and arguments of the tagged
function are run in the order as opposed
to
you know
any expression that contains these
functions i agree that that's a fine
thing to do i mean we could just add an
attribute just like we add listable you
know listable as an attribute
parallelizable would be an attribute i
don't know that it's really
parallelizable it's just that the
specific step in the evaluator of
evaluating
the parts of an expression can be done
in parallel it won't magically
parallelize any of the algorithms that
those functions use
right and i think also technically the
correct term is concurrent not parallel
well parallel means like it's running on
different
cores and stuff but concurrent just
means that like you you make no
statements about the order in which it's
going to run
so you're saying that the thing we have
then
is the concurrent what will be the
adjectival form concurrent to ball
what the heck would it be what is the
adjectival form of concurrent
able to be concurrent
concurrently why are attributes well
hold all let's hold all uh
uh
let's not hold all a ball
yeah okay
well concurrent just seems funny but i
mean uh
i mean
what's the relation with orderless
horrifying
orderless
ignores the spatial
relationship between the arguments and
this one ignores the time like
separation of them
she does orderless out of curiosity does
orderless reorder and then evaluate or
does it evaluate and then reorder
the reorders then evaluates
and actually the pattern matcher
can look at all orders
so the claim would be orderless spatial
independence
uh argument
concurrent not very good name
is temporal independence
four parts
of expressions
well that's interesting i mean we really
should try some experiments on this
here's just a very practical software
engineering question
is it the case that there are good
enough uh c analysis tools that even for
the kernel we could actually figure out
for the c kernel we could start figuring
out what blocks of code can run
concurrently
is that plausible
i don't think so i mean i i haven't
really seen much
stuff like that but i think the reason i
haven't is because it's it's like one of
these things with uh
you know with the module number where
it's sort of like if if you're being
really picky nothing is pure
and so
yeah especially c code it's very very
hard to know if something is really pure
so okay
so we've got some weird background noise
from somebody here the um
uh
okay well okay so let's just understand
our objectives and then
should wrap up fairly soon here but but
um
uh just our objectives right now
okay
you know one thing is
uh
you know
can we merge
the nick
and ian
evaluation graph technologies
is that a reasonable question guys
everybody's ambitious
it's more a question how would you make
an evaluator multi computation already
well okay but i'm i'm happy okay so
first sub step is
um
what is the single way
version
of next
you know graphs
and here okay so
but also how do you represent other
evaluators
i mean by other evaluators because the
trace graph is so deeply
like it's it is the standard evaluation
sequence
yeah but as you as you were about to say
it really doesn't have a huge dependence
on that does it i mean in other words
you could rewrite it
well i'm saying the horizontal edges are
the application of down values up values
or sub sub values or own values
not
arbitrary rules
that could be applied to arbitrary
sub expressions of the expression
okay but let's start okay fine
transformations but let's start with
that
let's start with the star value
transformations
in our language and see if we can
understand
what the analog of nick's got see what i
think is going to happen is next events
will come in a a down and up a sub and
an own
variety or something
that's my claim
and maybe an internal code variety
what's that
that's possible yeah
and then
so then the the idea would be
okay let's understand what the point of
evaluation graph will be
one is to be able to do graph
theoretical operations on it to
understand features of the code
that's one objective
another objective is
well i mean okay a long term objective
like a 35-year objective has been
can you understand a loop for example
and can you see it in the evaluation
graph
and just be able to kind of like a
puzzle piece
take a loop and put it somewhere else
for example
or see how to make a loop by just
extruding identical pieces of the
evaluation graph in other words
spatialize or i don't know what what
space this is
graphify
what would otherwise be a program
counter in other words can you get rid
of the program counter and instead
represent it in terms of
of uh kind of the
um uh dependency structure of this
evaluation graph
did that make any sense
i'm not sure are you are you wanting to
like step through this graph no i'm
saying imagine we have a piece of code
that is written as a loop
then let's look at the evaluation graph
that we get from the piece of code that
was written as a loop
ah
that graph will have many identical
elements in it
okay
now we say
instead of programming by writing a loop
we program by having
a way of putting down puzzle pieces that
correspond to the evaluation graph so
it's like physio programming
okay it's a generalization of visual
programming
did that make any sense
we can imagine this for example like if
you did a table you would see the
expression in the table reappearing many
times in this graph
yes but even if you had a for loop
that had a you know
what you would see is that for loop
would have a copy in the graph of boom
boom boom boom boom
and then what we could say is instead of
specifying it as a loop
sort of from the outside a function that
just does the looping
yeah here's the point table has internal
code that produces the separate elements
in the loop
what i'm saying is could we have a way
where you say okay i want those separate
elements in the loop i will make that by
just having this this
visual
uh you know collection of puzzle pieces
that i set down to represent that loop
make sense
nick this makes sense right
maybe
the thing is i think the rip at least
this representation if you looked at a
table or a do or whatever
it would be very verbose
sure
that's okay i mean that's okay
what's the problem respond to how many
times it runs
what
so if it runs if there's a hundred
iterations it's gonna be a hundred times
larger of a graph
yeah
great
that's what we want
we're trying to understand
okay the the real point this is a sub
point about evaluation graphs
you know when they're a program cap one
of the things that's horrifying in
procedural languages is the hidden state
of random values of variables random
program counters things like that
okay but in our evaluator there is a
little bit of hidden state
you know certainly when we have down
code there's hidden state
but the idea is to expose all hidden
state and make it explicit in the actual
structure of the evaluation graph
i'm saying so instead of instead of
saying there is a loop it goes around a
certain number of times with a hidden
internal variable internal code you just
say here's a graph that represents the
evaluation i want to take place
and then in a sense i mean nick it
reminds me a little bit of the metamath
system's proof mechanism
in the sense that in the end when you
want to do the proof it's just like like
ripple through the code
you have nothing to do it's a trivial
evaluation
whereas a loop right now
you know a loop requires that there's
internal code that's messing with
program counters and things
whereas what i'm saying is we're just
unrolling the loop to make it completely
explicit visually
graphically even though it's highly
redundant that's better than having some
implicit hidden part
that's the idea because then there's a
meta programming sort of meta level at
which you can say now i will be
constructing the graph
and but you can say it is just puzzle
pieces in a graph yeah it's not
there's no and and by the way when you
get to do that
there are potentially all sorts of
interesting generalizations you can make
and so on because it is now a graph
theoretic construction rather than a
hidden state type but you know hidden
state as in program counters and things
type construction it's also related to
the
unfolding the current network squares
indeed it is indeed it is
um
which which is you know people have done
exactly this in in in neural nets
of this um
uh
i mean in that case the reason they're
doing it and this will again relate to
what we're trying to do
is you know they're doing that partly so
that you have trainable pieces
so that you have something where
you know because in a
if you have a program counter type thing
there's no weight that you can identify
i guess that's that's why they're doing
it why why are they doing it that's the
reason right i mean it's been to be able
to do automatic differentiation and so
on yes
anybody know
wrong wrong group here
well maybe they're doing it to optimize
something how to actually put those
layers
on the gpu and so on so on
that's possible also
well anyway so
so i mean we've got the subproject of
argument concurrency which is a
different thing that is kind of somewhat
independent of the things we're talking
about here we've got this effort to
basically make the evaluation graph for
our evaluator
essentially the evaluation graph first
of all single way and then to understand
yeah this is i would say the path we
make the single way
evaluation graph for our evaluator then
we imagine what it would look like if we
added an argument concurrent
attribute
which i believe is equivalent
uh i think that's equivalent to the
multi-awareness of this whole thing is
that right
i think the multi-wayness is like i
apply an up value instead of applying a
down value
really
well okay this has to be proved
but then what we expect is first we have
the evaluation graph it's going to look
like this with different colors and
different whatevers
okay then we go
multi-way
um
and that gives us another dimension here
that is the bronze shield dimension of
different possible evaluation orders
it's like every horizontal line or every
horizontal edge here there would be many
horizontal edges
corresponding to different rules that's
correct or applying them at different
parts of the expression i think so
whereas
our standard evaluation is like this
certain thing in terms of down values of
values etc
yeah exactly but then then the question
would be okay then then what are we
trying to achieve from multi-computation
what we're trying to achieve is
that you know our normal programs
okay normally
you run the program you expect to get to
a fixed point from the single part of
evaluation
we then have new meta
evaluated so to speak like the evaluator
that says
just find me a path that gets to a fixed
point
even though i know there are ten fixed
points just find me a path
it may not be find me a path that gets
me to the smallest fixed point or the
fastest fixed point you know the fixed
point that's fastest to get to which may
or may not be the fixed point that you
would get to with a standard evaluator
just like for fibonacci there are faster
ways to do it than to do this step first
yeah i would think the graph for such a
thing would be much more horizontal than
this graph
which such thing
for for
like uh like a beam search like you're
trying to find a best path
yes
it's like lots of
transformation just from one state
directly to another
possibly
but i mean right
instead of doing depth first reversals
right but you see what i think we want
uh
you know it's an interesting question
whether
the thing the kinds of functions we're
going to want are basically ones that
involve rules transformation rules
plus our built-in functions
or whether we're going to want to see
the full evaluation graph
for essentially our
both built-in and user-added functions i
think both things might be useful i
think for these things that are more
like logic programming it might be more
useful to be able to explicitly give the
transformation rules rather than to have
them be assignments effectively
that makes sense to anybody
so just like nick has in his current
uh
in this token event goth with
multi-replace
be giving the rules
and then asking the questions in this
you know you could get the token event
graph that would be or some multi-way
graph
or you can have the meta evaluation
operator that says okay so so one meta
evaluator is replace repeated
okay so these are these are kind of
uh
you know
given a set of transformations
what are the meta evaluators
you could use
okay so so one of them would be just
replace repeated
of x per comma rules
that is our traditional fixed point yes
makes sense to people
another possibility would be saying find
optimal
result let's say
where we have an expert
rules
and a criterion
and in that case it means so this is
just
uh get to a fixed point
with the standard evaluation sequence
isn't
getting to a fixed point itself just an
assumption that you're making about the
evaluator like replace could be an
evaluator it's just a one-step evaluator
yes yes that's true
yes that's right i mean so so in
principle we could have replaced
repeated
and then we could say
exper rules traversal order goes to
whatever and we might have a different
set of results
right that would be another kind of
operation
i don't know how to parameterize that
traversal order but that would be the
idea so that's different from find
optimal result
which says try all possible paths
that lead to fixed points
return the one that maximizes the
criterion let's say
and you know then there's obviously a
path version of that where you also
could return the path you you know
and this is exactly like find replace
path this well
no no i'm sorry i'm sorry that there's
another case which is the find replace
path case
in that case we are specifying the
endpoints
we say expo one uh this is the wrong way
around but you know rules
expo one expert two
right now it's find a path
between those two expressions
and we've now got pretty nice technology
for that and i would say that that's
uh and then
oh yeah then we have the theorem proving
version of that
where we've got intermediate lemmas and
so on and we've got now some better
technology for doing that
okay this case here try all possible
paths that lead to fixed points leave
the one maximizes the criterion
and then
the other cases are things like
uh
you know probabilistic programming case
where you take a slice across all the
paths
that's another case or
um
uh there are probably cases which we
don't understand very well yet that
involves sampling an infinite evaluation
making sense
is this making sense to people
is that like lazy evaluation
maybe like i'm thinking about an
actually to have a replace repeated that
never reaches a fixed point but being
able to go out like as far into it as
you want
that would be one thing but there might
be other questions you can ask about an
infinite evaluation
i mean there's plenty of the cases i
mean i don't know
you know eg
you know a non-terminating combinator
expression non-terminating turing
machine
combinator etc
and i don't know what you're going to
ask about it but yes i agree it's it's
like lazy evaluation
one one
thing you can do
is lazy evaluation i don't think that's
the only thing you can do
i think you can make potentially and
this was something um
uh you know you can make potentially
infinite statements about these things
richard was talking about using
transfinite numbers to represent the
kinds of objects that you get by doing
these infinite non-terminating things
okay so you can actually reason about
the non-terminating object
rather than simply saying
show me it unrolled for such and such a
number of steps
um
okay well
uh we probably are running out of time
here but but did we have another oh wait
a minute nick had just sent through this
thing about propagator networks which we
didn't look at
um
find out what probably in a network is
what the heck is this
so this is the in connection with
grass and
programming i guess
it's like those red vertices are
propagators
other vertices have values
and then it's like you said you
put a puzzle piece
you populate somewhere
leo and then it propagates and fill all
the values
across the whole network
so this is like constraint programming
like people imagine we want to do with
spreadsheets and things
is that right
that was one of the early claims of the
wonders of spreadsheets was that you
could fill in some numbers and you could
sort of back calculate other ones
yeah we've never had a capability to do
things like this really
although you could state this in terms
of equations presumably
yeah like in in these examples i tried
to make it more
interesting by i
automatically add propagators in those
purple brigades you just you just
specify one
how you go from one value to another
and all the inverses are added
automatically into the graph
see what's interesting here and we have
the wrong people to really discuss this
maybe tony has opinions about this
is that we can imagine this is this is
in the category of evaluable graphs
graphs that have i mean
you know
like um
uh ian has one version of that
in
uh
what is it nest
treefold
yeah right
treefold that's one version of an
evaluable graph
where you put an operator on each node
and then you you know
run it so this in a sense some other
version of an evaluable graph i claim
a simple example like find an example
with temperature it's some somewhere in
the middle i think temperature converts
it the most obvious one
so you can just specify two propagators
how you convert from fahrenheit to
celsius and from
sticking one then
just two
and those inverses are added
and then you can just fill
any out of those three
and get all the other two values
and you can do it by intro
it's like yeah
right
and nick suggested that one application
of this to the tags
is that
we could also get
events that basically know their
inverses
so that you could basically take a tag
and if you need to reverse it that it
can become reversible
how does that relate to quantum
computing
i mean those gates
the tag is going to be super similar to
a quantum circuit i would think in that
situation
where the gates are the events
am i wrong
oh if you would think about
all those states and operators and gates
as just tensors floating around
then it's not really different from even
usual neural networks
so
well
where the neural net is where this event
is then one of our layer operators
basically
right right it has certain things that
come in and then it's a layer operator
and it goes out
oh very interesting
what a grand unification we're heading
for
okay so
i mean these are interesting these
networks i i'm i i mean i think it's a
pity roger isn't here but but um
uh
i mean
or actually michael
trot has also thought about these
because our formula
data system works basically like this
we should talk about that exposing that
because it should be the case okay so
let's say in the propagator network here
uh
i claim that formula data
actually i wonder what
let's say
what the heck is
this let's look at snell's law i don't
even know what formula lookup is
maybe it shouldn't be
okay
so formula data
okay but i believe that formula data
has this feature that it has all the
inversions
so you can fill in any set of num you
know parameters and it will fill in all
the other ones
does that make sense
so i think it's working in the same kind
of way
all right
uh
okay was there anything else we were
supposed to be covering and oh yeah this
is cool does this work
nick
the the sudoku one yeah no no
i think i never managed to make it work
but you think it should work
yeah i think it should work
it's just in this particular
implementation i just i don't know
okay but then then what this is okay so
this this propagator networks thing
is a version of a meta evaluator
if i'm not mistaken
there is a set of rules defined
i see that that is okay so that then
when there are two-way rules
and most of what we're talking about
here is one way rules but it's like
when there are
two-way rules
then you can get propagator networks
presumably then you can
and other things like that which is
different from these things here which
are essentially one-way stories
i'm not mistaken
okay
other things we should cover here last
minute or two
there was supplied but i don't know if
we have time for that
well that's a whole giant okay so that
that's a whole giant discussion i i i
think we should have broken that out
into a separate meeting really because i
think that's a
what's that
i think it's an ild story i mean this is
you know this has transitioned from
sort of a special project point to an
ild point
if i'm not mistaken i mean i don't i
still don't like the name
wow that's an interesting one
the most recent intermediate results of
previous applications of f
wow
yeah the test in nest while
is implicitly like a supplied together
with the next argument
yeah that would be cool
don't you think to be able to have the
sort of trace back of what did you last
see in the map wherever you were in the
map you know wherever you were in the
traversal order what did you last see
if it can be a little bit also like
moving or block map
yes
yes except for the block map with weird
multi-level
stuff
yeah these are like the the simple cases
map thread subset map block map i feel
like those are going to be very
specialized
right we'll have to find a way to
document these things probably in there
just like we do for things like you know
color function and so on we'll have to
put it in the actual thing that uses
them
i wish we had a better name than
supplied i don't really don't like
supplied
we've had we had a variety of names we
were thinking about right
we had the name there's like a whole
notebook
that lists
candidate names
um
where was that list hold on
this folder is becoming a mess and we
should clean it up this
multi-computation folder
uh
i think it's
well the remember in sw notes 8 but
maybe not for supplied is for using
oh that's the same thing as supplied
using is supplied
supplied is the best name
in my opinion so far
is supplied even on this list
it's confusing because it's not even
stated here
no
should be added this was from a meeting
before
uh oh suggested supplied
supplying
giving
i'm going to add this in here even
though it's counter um
okay so supplied
whoops
supplied supplying would be okay except
it's too long
giving
and the problem is that the most common
case
what is the most common case the most
common case is
a one argument form which doesn't say
what it's supplying correct
am i correct or am i not correct
no i'm expecting that
[Music]
no the most common case is going to be
something like
you know hash expression hash index
something like this
right that's the most common case the
case where you explicitly name the
things you want this is the case where
it's going to lexically scan to find out
what it should be picking up
right
that is the lexically scanned case yes
yes but that's going to be the most
common case that's one of what people
might write most of the time
the case where you explicitly say what
to pick up why would you do that if you
know the names of what to pick up why
would you not include them lexically
here like if you're writing code
like like
a package
yeah
you you're going to want to use
functions with why
why oh you mean you mean sub functions
here
i am never going me personally i'm never
going to want to use this with a pure
function because i'm
implementing things in packages i am
going to want to use supplied of lms
comma
i guarantee you will use this all the
time
and code in code where this is just
doing it right there maybe if i maybe if
i personally did more like interactive
coding that would be no you'll end up
using it for real code because it's
going to be a small sub piece that does
it right there
not something which which digs into the
functions here in any case doesn't
matter i mean because you might just say
f of hash index
right you you well
you're
then you're giving up on things like
attributes
some people don't don't use pure
functions very much
i'm guessing that's what you're talking
about i mean like you you just define a
function separately and then map with
that suppose you're defining a pure
function in line all right fine i mean
you will have to add boilerplate just to
use standard
function definitions in the language
with this you have to write function
with like three arguments if you want
hold attributes i know but but that's
unbelievably corner case i mean this
will be the most common thing is people
generalizing map index basically
but it doesn't really matter the name
has got to work
in the one argument case we're not doing
a name that is primarily for the two
argument case it's got to work for the
one argument case
yeah so
i think either way you write it it'll
like will naturally read
well
because if you have the one argument
case you're gonna see this the name
slots
and if you have the two argument case
you're not
yeah yeah i get it i get it either you
gotta go once the name works for the one
argument case i think it'll work for
both
okay
what about giving
like giving the arguments
well giving
index and expression and whatever
i just supply just is not sitting well
with me
it's not it's not
it's not
i don't like supply either i'm not sure
about giving though
giving is weird as well
all right we've got more thinking to do
on this they're both they're both
somewhat ambiguous i mean i know that
sometimes
is there any way that we can add some
specificity without making the name too
long
no it's got to be really short but it
will be a you can find a short word like
i know i know i know yeah so it'll be a
short
essentially branded name
just like
you know manipulate dynamic whatever all
these things right the name becomes the
brand of what it's doing
um
okay anyway for another time
all right good stuff
thanks everyone and actually let me just
check one thing here
um
right